- Hey, it's great to see you again.
- Hi it's so good to see.
I know it's been a long time, we did the
tonight show together and
you were just a child.
- I know and now I have a child.
- Now you have a child. I
know that's very exciting
- Thank You.
- How old is, how old is he now?
- He's 14 months.
- Oh okay.
- You know, I always made,
I always thought it was so
weird when parents were like,
he's 24 months. I'm like, no,
he's like two years old and
now I'm doing the same thing.
- Well exactly.
He's 14 months, one week, three hours.
- There's nothing scary than turning into
your parents because
I did it with my wife,
honey, did you touch the thermostat?
I go, that's what my dad would do.
He would always yell at me
for touching the thermostat.
And that became like a
huge deal in our house.
- I know I know but I mean,
if I could be as great
of a mother as my mom
was, then I'd be so Happy.
And thank you to my mom for
watching my son right now.
This is the first time that
I've been that I left him.
- Oh is that right?
- Yes.
- Oh okay.
- I know it's really scary.
- Now his name is Ever, or is that
short for something or what?
- No Ever is a name that
I just, I always loved.
And it's funny cause you
know you were talking
about your Italian family and you and I
have talked a lot about coming from these
very big and vibrant Italian families.
So it's always part of
the family tradition
that we tell what the name is and that
everyone can be involved in the decision.
And of course they
wanted to use all of the
existing family names like my cousin is
Gina Nicole and her sisters Nicole Gina.
And then there's Thomas
Anthony, Anthony Thomas.
And they're like, aren't you going to name
the baby Anthony? I'm
like, we have 10 Anthony's.
I think it's good. But you know,
they love the name Ever
when they found out
what it was, except
it's actually sounding a
little bit more like ever.
You know ever.
- Oh yeah. That's us now.
- With the accent.
- Where does it come from though?
- The name?
- Yeah. How did you
come up with that name?
- I think I'm probably founded on like a
baby name, Floggers or
something like that.
- Well, see, I never heard
that as a name until you,
until you're talking.
- I actually will say
that Alanis Morissette
son's name is ever, and I loved it so much
heard that she had it,
so I sort of stole it.
Oh no I can't believe I just said that.
- All right, now we get to the truth.
- I don't even think
my husband knows that.
- Really?
- No.
- Wow.
- I came up with it on my
own, I had a dream about it.
That's what I should've said,
It came to me in a dream.
- Okay. Okay.
Well it's too late now.
Was he Okay?
Did he have another
name picked out or did.
- No he was actually really, really great.
He was super on board with it,
except he waited until the last minute,
which was so hard for me
because like I wanted to know,
like we found out we were
pregnant and I was like, okay,
what are we naming the baby?
But he waited until like the ninth month,
which was very hard for me to
just like make the decision.
But once we did, yeah.
- Did you know ahead of time what it's
going to be, or you one of those people
that just wanted to wait and see.
- Whether it was a boy or girl?
- Yeah.
- No. I'm such a planner, You know me.
- Well, that's true.
- I needed, I needed to know.
And it was, it was really exciting.
- He's 14 months.
- 14 months.
- He's got his own place already.
They grow up so quickly.
- I know right, he has such a personality
and he actually really loves music,
which is amazing, but also like a little
scary for me that we might have a say
he might become a singer and he'll like,
be suddenly just going like
(Vocals)
I'm like, oh, do you want to harmonize?
You can do it.
- Now where they pressuring you since you
were a quote child bearing age to having
a kid and since you were the only child.
- He know it wasn't that, that bad.
But it was like,
it was more from the
whole big Italian family.
It's like your cousin Gino
already has a, you know,
you're next.
but I felt it was like
just a healthy amount of,
you know, we're getting older and
then they just the sad face.
So are you going to go and call
Kelly and give her an update
on how it's going.
- I would give her an update.
- Are you guys friends?
- We are friends.
We are friends because she's one of my
car show a bunch of times.
- I have seen it .
- And she's very competitive.
- Oh I will come on your show and you
can tell me what's a good like
mom car to drive.
- Oh a mom car.
- I really need something where it's like,
you know, it's still cool.
- Well, you know, see, it's fine,
cause when I was a kid
station wagon was there every
woman I knew I'm not
getting a station wagon.
I'm not going to be my parents.
I'm going to get one
of these new minivans.
That was a new thing, the
minivan had just come out.
And that was like the cool hip thing,
the PT cruiser and the
Pacifica with the sliding door.
And then minivans became sort
of now I want to get a vintage
station wagon.
It all goes around.
- Always right.
- That. Would you see yourself
as a station wagon or a mini?
- Well, I don't know.
I've so I just moved back to New York.
So I, you know,
I've lived out here for many years
and was driving constantly.
So now I don't need a car as much, but,
but I, I can totally rock a minivan.
I think I could do it.
- Right?
- Yeah.
And the minivan, like the
doors open automatically.
- Doors open automatically.
- Love that.
- And some days you kids were laughing
and he's my mom rocked a minivan.
That's what's going on.
- Of course.
- That's what's going to
happen as one of those deals.
- I'm ready.
I'm excited about it now.
- Any new tattoos? I think the last,
when you did the tattoo.
- So last time I saw you when
i got a tattoo that night.
- That night and what tattoo did you get?
- I can't say.
- Oh,
I'm not asking where it is,
but you can't even tell me what it is.
- Not a lot of people
will ever see that one.
No, I'm definitely.
I'm actually like,
I don't know.
The tattoo days are done.
I feel like I'm more in the
removal stage of life where I'm
looking at it and I'm like,
did I really need 20 butterflies?
Did I care about butterfly?
- Okay we know that
there are 20 butterflies.
- It's not a butterfly.
- Oh it's not
I think I'm going to
maybe even remove some.
And now also like I look
at my son and I'm like,
if he ever got a tattoo,
I would be so sad.
- No. Why?
Why would you be sad?
You have got one.
- Cause his little body and it's.
- But he's not getting a baby tattoo.
- I know I know.
- His body's not as big anymore.
We can't tattoo a baby.
Maybe become a Marine
and get a Marine tattoos.
- I think he should do whatever he wants.
But I'll definitely cry.
- I think he should do it every watch.
No mom ever told a bigger lie.
You should do whatever he
wants and not doing that.
- Well, hopefully we'll
cut this part out of
the segment for him to not watch this.
And 20 years ago you said that.
- You have a new album.
Is that of lullabies?
He's for the, for the baby?
- Yeah. It's a lullaby album.
It's called forever.
You know, get the name for ever.
- Oh for ever.
No, it all went over your head too.
Don't give me no, no, you didn't go.
Oh forever. You want, oh and then yeah,
at least I admit it.
So it's for ever.
Is it hyphenated?
Is it split or is it one word.
- It's called forever
but for me, you know,
I'll know in my mind or whatever and it's,
it's all it's lullaby songs,
but they're, you know,
sort of reinvented songs that I love or
- Untraditional?
- Yeah that I grew up
listening to Billy Joel
and guns and roses and I just,
they all have such
personal meanings to me.
I did a Kacey Musgraves song
on the album and it was the
first song I listened to The minute I
found out I was pregnant.
We listened to here comes the sun on the
way to the hospital in the morning.
So they all have very
special meanings for us.
But I think that, you know,
hopefully everyone will love it.
And even whether or not you have children,
it's very relaxing and calming.
- No but I think that's great because
I think your son will remember
that you just have that unconscious.
I have that unconscious
memory of my mother.
- Oh really?
- I do.
- Well, he loves, he
likes listening to his
favorite song is yellow on the album,
but he also really loves,
I can't get no satisfaction by
the rolling stones right now.
So we listened to both.
- Now you think he will become a singer?
Would you like him to become a singer?
- It's so it's so funny because I really
didn't think I had a lot
of feelings about it.
But now that he's such an
interest in music and he wants to
hear it, this album all the time.
I don't know.
I feel a little bit like.
- Can we play it back?
Didn't you say he could do
whatever he wants to do.
Well, that lasted about four minutes.
- What can I say.
- That was four minutes ago you said.
- I know.
- Yeah.